Marc is offsite this week, so we'll handle planning without him. He reviewed the agenda and said to proceed.
Three topics: hiring targets for Q3, PM process changes, and the launch feature freeze date.
On hiring — we're at capacity on the backend. Two engineers doing the work of four right now. I've been raising this for six weeks.
I know. The funding round closed last week so we finally have budget. What's realistic for Q3?
Two senior backend engineers. They need to ramp fast — so senior specifically. Someone who can be productive in two weeks, not two months.
Agreed. I'll open two senior backend roles this week. Target is offers out by end of June, start dates in July. Decision: two senior backend engineers, hired by end of July.
Should we use a recruiting agency or go direct? Our last hire through LinkedIn took four months.
Both. Agency for speed, our own network for quality. I'll reach out to three contacts this week who referred good engineers last time.
On the PM process — Léa, you wanted to change how specs land in the sprint?
Yes. Right now I'm writing specs during the same sprint they're being implemented, which means engineers are waiting on me. I need to be one sprint ahead.
The change: I own all feature specs, and they have to be written and reviewed by week three of the current sprint for the next sprint's work. No spec, no sprint commitment.
I love that constraint. No spec, no sprint commitment. That gives us time to push back on scope before we've started coding.
Decision: Léa owns all feature specs. Due by week three of each sprint for the following sprint's work.
I'll add a spec review step to our sprint planning template. Marc will need to sign off on anything touching the infra layer.
Feature freeze. Launch is end of September. When do we cut?
Two weeks before launch, minimum. We need time for regression testing, performance testing, and at least one week of customer beta. That puts the freeze at mid-September.
Mid-September works for product. We have eight customers signed up for early access. They need two weeks of stable builds to give useful feedback.
Decision: feature freeze two weeks before launch, hard cutoff. Only bug fixes after that. David enforces, no exceptions without my sign-off.
Understood. I'll add the freeze date to the project header in Linear so everyone sees it on every sprint board.
One housekeeping item: should we schedule a monthly architecture review once the new engineers are on board?
Good idea. Let's revisit that once we know who we've hired. Put it on the Q3 retrospective agenda.
Works for me. I'll also need Marc to walk the new engineers through the AWS setup on day one — should we block time on his calendar now?
Yes, I'll ask him to keep a two-hour onboarding block free during the July onboarding week. Good catch.
I'll send a summary of today's decisions to Marc so he's not out of the loop.
Perfect. Hiring by end of July, specs due week three, feature freeze two weeks out. Good session.